So now I want to ask you a question.
So given this quality function Q,
and assuming that our utility function
is the log function,
since we saw that for some values of this state
the best action--
the action with the highest quality is 'hold'
and other values is 'gamble,'
there must be a point at which there is a crossover--
where the two values are approximately equal.
So what I want you to tell me is:
to the nearest million, what is that crossover point C?
That value of state--
that value of the amount of money that I currently have
to say that I'm indifferent between the 2--
that if I have C dollars, then my quality for gambling
is the same or approximately the same
as my value for holding.
What value of C to the nearest million is that true of?
And just to make it easier for those who can't divide by e in your head,
we'll use the log10 logarithms rather than the natural logarithms
so that the log10 logarithm of a million is 6.
Tell me what the crossover point is to the nearest million.